Hey, Vsauce. Michael here. And when the pyramids
of Giza were built, the tallest was 147 meters
tall, making them the tallest things humans
had ever built. And they remained that way
for nearly 4,000 years. It wasn't even until
the 1300's that we finally got around to making
something taller, a cathedral in England.
So, does that mean that the Great Pyramids
of Giza are the "Best tallest structures of all time?"
Well, to find out more, all aboard the BOAT.
So, what is a building? Well, technically,
a building is a structure in which at least
50% of its height comes from floor plates
where people can live, work, chill out, it
has to be habitable. Any less than that and
it's not a building, it's a tower. After the
Lincoln Cathedral finally surpassed the height
of the pyramids, a number of churches continued
to be built that kept breaking and setting
new records. The next long-term record holder
was the Eiffel Tower.
It was the tallest thing, ever in history,
that we had built, for about 40 years in a
row. It was finally surpassed by the Chrysler
Building in New York, a personal favorite,
which was then quickly bested by the Empire
State Building. Now, the Empire State Building
is interesting in that it was the first structure
ever built by man that was so tall, were you
to jump off the top of it, you would actually
reach terminal velocity before you hit the
bottom. It was the first structure we'd ever
built that was so tall, rather than just continuing
to accelerate as you fell, you would actually
stop accelerating because you would reach
the fastest possible speed your limp body
can fall at. In the mid 1950's, something
weird started to happen. Humans started to
build radio and TV towers. These things could
be way taller than the buildings that we'd
made previously that had to be habitable.
And so, ever since the Empire State Building
had its record broken by a TV tower, all these
other famously tall buildings, the Petronas
Towers, Tapei 101, the World Trade Center,
the Willis Tower - formerly Sears Tower - none
of them have ever, within their existence,
actually held the title for being the tallest
"thing" we've ever built. There was always
a radio or TV tower somewhere that was taller.
Up until quite recently, and for quite a while,
the record for the tallest thing ever built
by humans went to the Warsaw radio mast in
Poland. It's visually incredibly striking,
because there aren't any other sky scrapers
around it. It's all alone, being very tall.
Well, that was until 1991, where some workers
exchanging guy-wires made a mistake and the
whole thing started to bend and then snapped
in the middle. There's no video of the event
happening, but it would have been similar
to this collapse, though much, much taller.
After the Warsaw radio mast collapsed, the
KVLY-TV mast in North Dakota became the tallest,
still standing, structure built by man. But
recently, buildings have made a comeback.
And to check that out, we're going to have
to travel to the Middle East. This is the
first time I've ever touched the Nile.
Tadaaa. Ok, so that was me dipping my
waterproof camera into the Nile. If you were to take
the entire length of the Nile River and stand
it up on its edge, perpendicular to the Earth,
it would reach into outer space about this
far, which is pretty impressive. But where
does the space shuttle orbit? And where does
the International Space Station orbit? This
far away? This far away? Maybe this far away?
Actually, if this pink, inflatable "Horrible
Bosses" ball was the Earth, the space shuttle
would orbit about right there. It's incredible,
but it's possible because the shuttle, and
the International Space Station, travel so
quickly. They travel so quickly around the
Earth that instead of seeing one sunrise
and sunset every 24 hours, they see 16.
But don't be jealous. You can easily see more
than one sunrise and/or sunset in a day by
taking advantage of tall structures. So, let's
take a look at the tallest structure, the
current record holder for the tallest thing
humans have ever built, the Burj Khalifa in
Dubai. The height of this building blows my
mind. You can literally watch the sunset from
the base of the building, and then take a
super-fast elevator all-the-way up to the
top and watch the same sun set again. In fact,
the difference
in timing between sunset at the base and the
top is so significant, the Dubai Islamic Affairs
department actually had to make a ruling about
when you can start, and break, your fast during
Ramadan inside the building. People above
floor 80 or higher have to actually wait to
start eating 2-3 minutes after the people
at the base, because the sun hasn't yet set
for those at the top. But before you head
to Dubai to watch the sun rise or set twice
in a day, keep in mind that the only height
you actually need to see two sunrises or sunsets
is the height of your own body. Try this the
next time you're at a beach.
Watch the sun rise or set over
the water. Water is important because it won't
have the terrain and hill issues that land
does. Now let's say you're watching a sunset.
Begin by laying on your stomach. Watch the
sun set and as soon as the very last little bit
of the sun goes below the horizon, quickly pop
up into a standing position and voilá,
you'll see the sun's back - part of it's back -
and it will set another time.
If you take a stopwatch and record the time
between the first setting and the second setting
that you witness and measure the height
of your eyes when you're laying down and when
you're standing, you can use those numbers
to calculate the radius of the Earth.
XKCD took this a little bit further by proposing
the "Double Sunset Date." Take your date out
to the beach in a cherry picker and sure
enough, it was calculated, given the speed
of a cherry picker, all you have to do is move
about 6 feet up and you can watch a beautiful
sunset all over again.
To put things in perspective, the Burj Khalifa
is nowhere near as tall as Mount Everest.
But the tallest structure that we could potentially
build wouldn't be as tall as Mount Everest,
it would be way, way taller. Like, into space
taller. Of course, the problem with building
things that are really tall is that they get
heavier and heavier and have to support their
own weight. But only up to a point.
If a structure was so tall that it wound up
at the altitude of a geostationary orbit,
it would start to feel a new force, not just
a gravitational force downward, but all of
the sudden this new, centrifugal force up and outward.
And so, a building that tall could be stable
through tension. And more than 35,000 km
high.
This kind if structure is known as a "Space Elevator."
Unfortunately, there aren't any materials
known to science today that are strong enough
to make building something that large feasable.
With the exception, maybe, of Carbon Nanotubes,
or Boron-Nitrate Nanotubes. Of course, if
we went to a smaller celestial body, like
the Moon, we could build one today out of
stuff like Kevlar.
There are a lot of different things that we
have to be wary of when we build a space elevator.
For instance, how do we dodge space debris?
One solution is to attach the Earth side of
the cable to a boat in the ocean that can
maneuver around and move the elevator away
from dangerous obstacles.
Another interesting point is that the taller
the cable, the faster the far end of it will
be traveling. In fact, if the cable is more
than 50,000 km long, its far end will be travelling
near escape velocity and simply walking outside
could take you to the Moon. But why build
a space elevator? Well, because it would be
awesome. But also for better reasons too.
For instance, right now, in order to send
a pound of material into orbit, it costs about
11,000 dollars. But with a space elevator,
we could send the same amount of material
into orbit for only about 100 bucks. That
difference is so significant that Philip Ragan
has said that the first country to deploy
a space elevator will have a 95% cost advantage
and will possibly be able to control all space
related activities. Alright, so here you see,
in the mirror, Alex
playing guitar while she holds a camera in
her mouth and records us. Impressive. I'm
here with Kristen from Barely Political. She's
visiting London and if you enjoyed this episode
of BOAT, check out other episodes, I've got
them all up there.
And as always,
thanks for watching.
Oh and check out Kristen's
channel right there. Bye! Bye.